speaking of crypto
no no
i want to start with drake playing rubet
on the [ __ ] game floor yeah let's see
this bring this [ __ ] up which is
so wild
and we you know we were speculating you
know how much on drake's instagram story
how much did they pay this dude because
you know he's got nike deals he's got
all kinds of money
he had an extra seat for my laptop may
as well and he's playing i don't think
it's ruben i think it's uh
the other one isn't it no no stacks or
stacks
whatever it's a crypto betting
site yeah
it looks like steak steak that's what it
is that's the biggest one
and i believe that is um
a certain vpn company in his task bar
which is it
what is it
it's just a beautiful round icon
that i love to use when watching
tv shows in foreign countries that i'm
not is it express or north
um it rhymes with george okay okay yeah
we don't [ __ ] with that one no or do we
do we do we do [ __ ] with that yeah it's
the other one
you don't even know yeah it's the other
one no but i'm saying which one sponsors
the podcast is what i'm saying
jord
i think it's express
did we we have both
i i yeah it's been both it's been jord
and it's been
expressed mixed
express yeah it's express endured just
full discretion i've used both and i
love both
uh-huh yeah
anyway anyway so he's he must have
gotten paid like millions of dollars to
post that but
here's the thing
maybe it's on that
maybe he's just he's just [ __ ] crypto
gambling which is even crazier pretty
crazy flex yeah
nah there's no way that's not ad yeah
it just feels too
whatever but okay
so he did this and then right like
within a couple hours of seeing this
i was looking at um
the baby posted something
uh i was on his instagram
and it was like because i saw an image
of him kanye and
antonio brown
like at a game together and so i went to
his page and he had this whole carousel
of all the [ __ ] he did
um
and i was mainly looking because i just
wanted to see is there any more images
of kanye's outfit okay and the one that
because the thing that drew me in is
like on the image it seemed like there
were holes but i couldn't tell and then
i saw a separate video where there were
holes in the mask so he could breathe
okay but the video is him fully just
sitting and interacting with like
people next to him through that mask i'm
like that's [ __ ] crazy but it's kind
of dope anyway
so go to one frame
and
the baby
he's performing in vegas so he he flew
to a basketball game and then he
uh
then he then he goes to perform in vegas
and while he's performing in vegas
he [ __ ] takes his shoes off and just
throws them in the crowd
after he had already thrown his shirt
off and thrown into the crowd so he's
just literally giving away his clothes
which is so wild like he takes a boot
off of one foot and then just
[ __ ] tosses it in the crowd i'm like
that's
so dope that you don't care about your
clothes like that
i mean like what if he kept going that's
that's what the hell i thought was like
oh okay yeah yeah
boxers
people were like holy [ __ ] throws those
into the crowd
and then
he's got a condom on oh [ __ ] just
soft dick but he's got he's got a condom
on he peels it off throws into the crowd
people like oh oh no handful of pubes
butt plug oh damn it
i want to think about that
oh damn it
damn it just hit somebody in the head
well bro so then what the the next frame
he's back in the shirt okay and he's
talking about how he he he he had his
assistant go grab him a shirt
and he's like i got a whole new outfit
on you he's just flexing and then but at
the end of the clip he goes
i'm gonna go right now and i'm gonna
place a bet
on
and it sounds like he goes rubet i go
what the [ __ ] is going on i'm like drake
the baby i'm like did they just promote
i didn't realize that it was steak at
the time yeah my brain is melting
thinking that ruben just got the baby
and drake to perform
or to promote this [ __ ] within a couple
days of each other or whatever it is so
i run the clip back and he says roulette
i'm like oh damn
but it just it just bugged me out for
like one second and i had a whole
meltdown for 30 seconds so i'm like why
do these [ __ ]
why are they why do they do this man
like these people with these crypto
casinos are just taking over it has to
stop this needs to stop
now this
this is not okay
this needs to stop now this is cancer
[Applause]
is that why it's called rubet because of
roulette but it's just they replace it
with a b
sound like roulette i don't know rubet
it's an easy one yeah
uh yeah but
in order to get drake like
the paycheck for that must have been
like in the tens of millions yeah for
one story post gigantic right i mean
those the amount of money that steak has
made is so [ __ ] crazy was it like 40
billion
some no it's not that big but
that's that's a [ __ ] ton of money what
is it like a hundred bajillion
he's just like
that's what crypto completely [ __ ] on
what i was about to say yeah
what is it 40 billion well now whatever
i say is not going to be as cool
it's got to be like 70 trillion dollars
right
no but i remember watching one of those
videos when they were breaking down
rubet and stuff like that and you can
like track
whatever they use
the account that they use for deposits
and people have deposited in steak
at that point it was like something
crazy like a billion dollars worth of
ethereum or something like that
it's nuts
yeah
yeah what a
what a b dick comment of mine to make
what these crypto casinos have to stop
i'm just jealous
what a small dick loser thing to say
exactly
oh you don't like money yeah huh weird
[ __ ] weirdo dude